why are we not willing to open ourselves
to the richness within it's perfectly
obvious
well drugs have different levels of
richness
television is the plug-in drug it's it's
an electronic device the average
American spends six hours a day watching
TV the average American
so that means those of us who don't
watch some people must be watching 12
hours a day worth of TV I don't even
understand how they get any work done in
Southern California we occasionally stay
with people who there's a TV set in
every room including the John on
all the time and in if you're talking to
someone and and you reach out and turn
off the TV they react as though you had
slapped them I mean it's uh it's the
most outlandish social faux pas you can
commit you know it's a an
incontrovertible Act of social
maladaptation that is shocking to people
even if you just suggest turning it down
they just you know it's like light they
say well we need light so let's turn on
a TV
the TV both or neither you can't figure
it out barely ever a little of it a
little of everything the surface
the surface
Cult of the surface how everything looks
how everything is presented it's uh it's
really Insidious depth has no currency
out of and speaking of currency to close
the metaphor about print uh money in the
modern manifestation is entirely a
print-created institution I mean before
that people
traded in heavily pressed coins that
were essentially works of art and you
save them up in a can under your bed and
that's what wealth was was somebody who
had a bag of gold coins stuffed under
their mattress the modern notion of
money where single individuals control
hundreds of millions of dollars which
they never see which is moved around
electronically uh we we are becoming
more and more dealers in air this whole
problem with the stock market is based
basically that the stock market no
longer represents real things it is a
market of money money for itself money
as the major commodity and product of
the culture so that people can make
millions without producing anything so
the notion of the accrual of wealth has
been entirely divorced from the notion
of the production of useful and enduring
objects this sets us up for the kind of
cheesy
crassness that touches everything our
whole world is like a a low budget TV
program and I really think this is what
happened after World War II The
Generation that fought through World War
II believed they were defeating fascism
to create a new world of Plenty
abundance and by implication meaning
although they never said that and they
discovered instead that the only way
this could be done was on a on a
shoestring budget
and so everything is made badly and
people live in mobile homes in vast
trailer courts in desert communities and
consume the richest thing in their lives
is television
you know they're they they believe that
what's coming off the screen this is I
maintain the attraction of Dynasty and
these kinds of shows you might as well
be rich
you know then you can have problems with
drug addiction broken down Ferraris
scheming and scheming in laws and uh
murderous
bills for your clothing it's uh
vicarious existence is being peddled on
every level and vicarious existence
bleeds off Soul we need to try to come
tangential with the real get our own
Ferraris if that's what you care about
which is perfectly reasonable but not to
watch movies about them play baseball if
you like baseball not glue your ass to
the chair and consume these things as
spectator sports there is no uh there is
no brain growth on the part of rats that
watch other rats that play
[Music]
thank you